Hey !
Greg !
Ça va?
Hum hum.
Tu vas au boulot là?
Bah moi tu sais j’ai changé, j’ai changé de taf.
J'ai décidé d'ouvrir ma boite, mais bon...
Ça s’est pas vraiment passé comme prévu.
Du coup j’suis à nouveau chargée de recrutement.
Et euh… Si je devais me recruter pour diriger une société je…
J’y réfléchirai à deux fois quoi avant de me…
De me prendre.
Nan mais je rigole mais…
C’est... C'est pas facile…
Depuis que... Que t’es plus là, c’est pas…
C’est un peu la traversée du désert quoi…
Ok, je comprends…
Nan moi non plus, j’aurais pas forcément envie d’adresser la parole à quelqu’un qui est parti du jour au lendemain, sans donner d’explications.
J’ai tout ce que je mérite hein!
C’est à dire rien!
Rien,parce que je suis qu’une merde!
Et une merde?
Bah qui a envie de donner une seconde chance à une merde hein?
Bah personne! Personne!
Parce qu’une merde c’est...
Hey!
Lilian…
Toujours aussi beau gosse…